You
Hello everybody oh fuck hold on hold on I forgot to turn my fan off if you if you hear if you hear a loud background sound it's my friend let me turn it off I forgot to do that okay sorry I was gonna turn off the fan when I go live and I I forgot to do that I'm sorry about that it's it's getting a little loud
hot here someday so I had to have my fan on so I don't hear it well cuz cuz I turned it off I turned it off just now I hope you guys are doing well I'm sorry I'm sorry if I
If I hope I can't talk am I quiet am I quiet am I too quiet please let me know oh god my brain is over the place no no you go to little you're fine
oh okay okay all right I was I was just making sure I hope you didn't miss me too much yesterday cuz now now I'm here now I'm here once again so don't don't worry no need to miss me
um num num num num num num today we are going to be playing the polar bear game it's a it's a pretty old game it took me a while to set it up and stuff but that's how it is with retro games sadly I love them so much but a lot of them are a big pain to
just to set up also why the hell does my model keep pausing what the hell do I need to like do something I wonder if I need to have my iPhone plugged in the whole time or something what the fuck I missed me
that's really sweet I I think it's really sweet to hear that I have been missed you know cuz like it how do I explain it like when someone tells me that they miss me it's like this nice feeling of like oh so so it means that my absence
uh means something you know cuz like when like you're gone and nobody misses you that it makes you feel like well what's the point of streaming right nobody misses me anyway so
uh why stream but but because you do miss me uh it makes me go like oh they they actually do miss me and and they think of me so like that gives me like a big reason to uh to stream you know like if
you weren't here I wouldn't have a reason to stream to be honest and it wouldn't be fun you know so uh yeah that's what we're gonna do today I am gonna try to open the game um and when I open the game you know
same thing we do every gaming stream let me know how the sound of the game is let me know if uh if you can see everything or if there's anything to change and stuff like that
I say I can't wait for your smm stream honestly honestly me too I'm really excited for that as well I'm excited for for tomorrow stream did you miss us though of course I did that's why that's why I was yapping on on my alt twitter yesterday so imagine
I responded to a lot of Maros because I missed you guys if I didn't miss you I would be like man fuck this no bear don't give a fuck I'm I don't want to I don't want to talk
I don't give a fuck
but yeah yeah I definitely miss you and I'm so happy to be back here but yeah I'm really excited for tomorrow stream but I am really nervous because I'm really scared that the background noise on everything that the microphone picks up is gonna like
make make my smr stream like not as good as the rest of the girls but I I I hope that it's not gonna but it's not going to bother you too too much and and you know and I don't know that the best that I can provide you with at the moment will be good enough for now anyways
I'll I promise I'll do my very best to make it a good smr stream um another thing I don't know if that is smr stream if the vod is gonna stay up or not because as you've noticed some of my gen mates who did smr they had their vods like bonked by youtube so yeah
if you want to archive tomorrow's smr stream by all means go go ahead and do that because again you you can't know with youtube at the moment what's gonna happen so um yeah if you want to be like extra careful or something like that
um be be sure to archive it and I'll I'll post a link but hopefully hopefully hopefully it doesn't hopefully it doesn't get taken down but if it does well oh well what can you do
oh my god be gentle it's okay oh I well don't worry when um when I do smr I get extremely uh extremely gentle to be honest and whisper and oh lovey dovey and cutesy and yeah
um I'm gonna make sure to do my best to keep you as comfy as I can tomorrow so you're in good hands with me don't worry about that
I'll I'll do my best I'll do my best for my OG sons
uh okay okay enough enough yapping I am going to uh blah blah blah blah blah I'm going to
uh open
open the game I'm sorry my my brain is kind of kind of brain dead even even I took even I took a nap before I stream today
blah blah blah okay I'm I don't know why I'm nervous to open the game but I am for some reason
because because because if I open the game and there's something I need to fix it's gonna be it's gonna be a mess to fix it's gonna be a mess to fix
because like the game just like completely shits itself if you like I'll tap out of it
what's the art for the smr stream finished um in time for though um it's it's it's not finished yet no it's not finished yet but uh it says that it roughly takes eight days
uh for the art to be done so it will be ready in a few days so so you will see the art soon very soon
um okay let's let's open a game and see what happens
lars look at the stars the north stars right above us and if you trace let me know if you can see the game
if you can hear it and if it's too loud or not it's also known as Ursula major which means
the great bear the great bear the great bear stars don't look like a bear to me
tell me dad why would they call that constellation the great bear
let me think I'm sure my father told me once but I must admit I don't really I don't look like me
do you think that Igor the whale might know oh I'm sure he would you know so many things you must know
okay then tomorrow I'll go see Igor he will surely be able to tell me why they call that constellation of stars the great bear
your model moved you I see fuck why is my model oh my fucking god what the fuck hello is this better
I knew something is gonna go wrong I fucking knew it is this better
I'm a midget now is this better is this is this better
I see in the middle of the game I see the game fucking low resolution game moment
it what no it was not on purpose this game is just really something looks good okay let's keep playing
that's me hello hello I'm Lars I'm I see start our adventure choose one of my friends are you gonna you will be your
playmate and remember I have I have a friend I have bunny friend I have big moose friend
we have walrus we have our and we have doggo which friend so we start with snow berries
Lars no boss oh my god where should we start bunny let's start with she be let's start with
my friend she be sure of your choice yes I'm sure don't forget which animal you chose
I will allow you to come back to your game where you okay I know this is the north pole Lars has always lived here
there are two ways to follow Lars's adventure you can play with Lars and help him along on his adventure in the game
or you can follow his adventure like a storybook story I want to tell my life like a storybook
a nice and cold fresh air Lars gets ready for his trip a great adventure lies ahead yeah
adventure we'll have to catch some food okay I need to catch some food Lars's father often takes
fishing
wait does it play it for me wait no no no it's display it for me what the fuck that's not what I thought
story man what is this shit I'm exiting hold on I'm exiting the game and then I'm gonna reopen
it again I'm stupid I'm sorry I'm stupid I'm sorry okay I didn't realize it's too hard for I see such
you need a story mode that's why I know I know I know I'll be your playmate and remember our adventure
Lars snow paws okay sure of your choice yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah don't forget which animal you chose
I'll allow you to come back to your game where you left off by the way is the game too loud Lars has always lived here
there are two ways to follow Lars is again too loud by the way play with Lars and help him along on his adventure in the game
or you can follow his adventure like a storybook look at my cute paw play with Lars and help him oh and one last thing if you need any help during the game
shut up I don't need help I'll give you some help my pie is so cute okay okay okay okay now I can do that don't care okay okay
before we go and see Igor we'll have to catch some food yeah let's time to do a hunt
when a fish jumps out of the water catch it as fast as you can for some fishy use your mouth to move my paw
and lick on the fish as they jump out of the water we have to catch six to win yay
hey let's catch fishy one two three four wow I'm doing so good look at me go wait
we have enough supplies can I catch that let's go and see Igor he's the oldest one in the north
look at me I'm an amazing memory
oh no what happened
no who did this to you hi Igor what happened to you
Lars I'm stuck in this fishing net please help me get out by pulling on the ropes to put them in the right order
we'll have to use all our strength to pull these ropes
oh no how are I need to help
oh no no like a dish
oh no I don't know what I'm doing I'm stupid I need a decent to help me
no
I need to save the whale
oh no
maybe like this
like this
no I like this like this
no no no no no no no
no I'm stupid like this
oh I feel better already
give give hatpats to the whale give hatpats to the whale so that he
pat pat pat whale you're going to be okay I'll rescue you
I feel better already
I'm glad
uh how do I get him on it
no no
what the heck
I'm stupid
I don't know what I'm doing
no don't look at me so soon
oh I feel better already
Igor shut up I'm trying
I'm scared
I'm scared I don't know how to set him free
maybe this
maybe like this
I feel better already
oh how do I
oh I feel better already
shut up Igor I'm trying to save
I feel better already
I have to think Igor.
No! I'm making this worse!
I'm making this worse.
No.
How do I move this one?
I need to...
I can't move it like this.
Do I need to be numb?
Maybe no?
No?
Please Igor, stop making that touch face.
It makes me sad.
No.
I don't know.
Take Igor to all of Wonderland.
He obviously just being tied up.
No! I want to save him.
Why is this so difficult?
Pull that one above.
The bottom all the way right.
Way wide.
It's so over.
Igor, I'm trying to help.
I don't know how.
Please.
I feel better already.
Can you click this number for help?
No, it doesn't.
It doesn't do anything.
Can't you just help me?
I feel better already.
No, that does this.
Help.
Come on.
Good Lord, keep it up.
Little Chris won't help, but I want help.
I need your Jesus help.
I'm too stupid.
Good Lord, keep it up.
You're doing great.
I feel better already.
I think you're nearly there.
I don't know, I feel like I'm making everything worse.
I'm so bad at this game.
I'm supposed to be for children.
Why am I so stupid?
Please Igor, you're making it difficult.
Every time he says those things, it makes my brain hurt.
No.
I'm making it worse.
What's that? This is a good idea.
What's that?
All right.
Now I move this thing.
Good Lord, keep it up.
Come on.
No.
Hi.
Doing the bear doesn't do anything.
Clicking the bear doesn't do anything.
Fuck.
Why did you do the puzzle game though?
Because I thought I'm smart.
Because it's a children's game.
But I'm fucking stupid.
Pull it from the other side.
Okay, but what's the other side?
There's two sides left, right, up and down.
I don't know what other side means.
You have to tell me specifically what side and what number of the row.
You are too smart for the game.
No, I'm not.
I'm stupid.
I have to save Igor.
I have to save Igor, but I'm too smart.
Good Lord, keep it up.
I'm too stupid.
Pull from the front.
Okay, that's not smart.
Come on.
Left four.
That's as much as far as it goes.
Pull four.
Try the fourth arrow on the left.
Well, that's how it does.
I have to save Igor.
I'm really stupid.
I feel better already.
Igor, shut up, please.
Oh my fucking God.
I'm so embarrassed, honestly.
I was like, I can do this.
This is a children's game.
But I'm too fucking stupid, apparently, for that.
Oh, great.
I feel better already.
I'm gonna die, please.
I feel so bad.
It's over for me.
It's so over for me.
I feel better already.
Stop moaning.
Stop moaning, Igor, please.
I feel better already.
Please, stop being...
Please, I'm trying to think and you're not helping me.
Come on, not like this.
Why can't I not move this one?
Come on.
This is the first fucking thing.
I feel better already.
Guys, I need...
Whatever.
Oh my God.
Hello?
Hello? Why can't I click anything?
What is this?
Whenever you want to come back and play with me,
all you have to do is to become a friend that you chose at the beginning.
See you soon.
No, not like this.
No!
What the fuck?
Oh my fucking God.
Please.
Okay, I'm sorry.
But I'm not dealing with Shibi's ropes, okay?
I'm too stupid to untie Shibi's ropes, okay?
Igor is going to be okay.
Shibi's gonna come back, she's gonna untie Igor
and he's gonna be fine.
I think I'm smart enough to deal with Shibi's ropes.
I'm sorry, she's gonna have to deal with that herself.
Are you sure of your choice?
We're gonna go somewhere.
It will allow you to come back to your game where you left off.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Damn, I should have just went with the story mode
and pretend that I'm doing it.
You can play with Lars and help him along on his adventure in the game.
Or you can follow his adventure like a story mode.
Lars, please.
Please, let me do something.
Please, I'm too stupid for this.
No, no.
Wait, what?
Wait, what? No!
No, there's a minute for me to have to do this again!
Before we go and see Igor, we'll have to catch some food.
Help me catch the fish.
When a fish jumps out of the water,
please tell me I don't have to do this shit again.
No, please.
Please, no.
Please, let me go somewhere else.
Please, I'm begging.
And please.
Please.
Please, let me have fun.
Oh my fucking god.
Whenever you want to come back and play with me,
all you have to do is click on the friend that you chose at the beginning.
See you soon.
This is the worst fucking stream ever.
What the fuck am I doing?
Please.
Why am I stupid?
Oh my god.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry I'm stupid, okay?
I'm sorry I have no brain cells left.
Hello?
I know who you are, shut up.
Choose one of my friends.
He will be your playmate and remember our adventure.
Oh my god, okay.
Be sure of your choice.
Don't forget which animal you chose.
It will allow you to come back to your game where you left off.
Please.
I'm low-key tempted to do fucking stories.
Because I'm too fucking stupid.
And help him along on his adventure in the game.
Or you can follow his adventure like a storybook.
Okay, I need your opinion.
What do you Snowberries think I should do?
You can play with Lars and help him along on his adventure in the game.
Should I keep trying to get rid of those fucking ropes?
Or should I just give up and do fucking story mode?
Oh my god.
The animals are just save slots.
Okay, that makes sense.
I'm fucking stupid.
Just try again, you can do it.
Okay, I have one more chance to do the rope.
Story mode. You have to get good.
I'll never get good.
You can play with Lars and help him along on his adventure in the game.
I'll give him my room and go.
Okay.
If you need any help during the game, just click on Lars and he'll give you some help.
No, he won't.
Why is he lying?
He's like, oh, if you need some help, click Lars and he will help you.
No, he didn't.
He didn't fucking help me.
I was clicking him like not fucking stop.
I was clicking Lars not stop for help.
And he didn't give me any help.
What the fuck?
The narrowed.
Oh fuck.
Okay, at least I can fish.
At least I have that going for me in this life.
Lars is like fucking stupid.
He's the oldest one in the north.
He has an amazing memory.
Lars, you're good.
Oh god, I'm gonna have to listen to Igor Mon again, please.
Hi, Igor. What happened to you?
Lars, I'm stuck in this fishing net.
Please help me get out by pulling on the ropes to put them in the right order.
We'll have to use all our strength to pull these ropes.
Oh god, here we go.
Keep Lars, keep it up.
Oh god.
Oh god, oh this is gonna be so fucking bad.
Oh no, no, no, no, no, no.
Please.
Oh, I feel better already.
I don't, I feel like shit.
You know, when I planned going back to the wild for a visit with OG suns,
this is not what I had in mind.
Please stop moaning.
You're making it very difficult for me to rescue you, okay Igor?
I'm sorry, but you're gonna have to shut up.
I see which rope affects...
I can't even fucking talk because he starts moaning.
Which rope affects the fourth one?
This one? This one on this?
Please.
No.
I love how I click Lars.
And he's just not fucking helping in any fucking way.
Igor is a freak.
The second one on the top, bottom, and the second one.
Good Lars, keep it up.
Please, Igor, I, I...
How did you get yourself in this mess?
Like, what are you doing?
Please, help.
Man.
You sure this is a children's game, you know?
I thought so, but I guess I'm too fucking stupid for a children's game.
This stupid rope.
Why can't I just bring my fucking scissors?
Maybe you're too smart, I think like a child.
I feel better already.
Please, Igor, stop.
Good Lars, keep it up.
Please.
Marisa, you got the ropes for me.
Shut up, Igor, please.
Oh my fucking God, please.
Good Lars, keep it up.
Okay.
Oh.
Please, please don't do anything like that.
Mmm.
Now what?
This stupid fucking rope, fucking die.
Please.
Good Lars, keep it up.
Come on, please.
Please, this should be good enough.
Please, you literally don't have any ropes around you anymore.
Please, you can literally escape this.
What do you mean?
You're not even attached to him anymore.
Please, Igor, please.
Oh, you can escape.
I'm begging.
Oh my fucking...
Oh my God, why is life so difficult?
God damn it!
Ah!
I feel better already.
Well, if you feel better, just freaking get out.
Oh my God.
Why?
Why, why?
Why, why, why?
Why?
Why should we make this difficult?
Why she has to make ropes all over this way?
Why do we need to get all rope of his PNG?
I guess so, cause like, he can't escape.
Come on.
I can't believe he's not helping me.
Very nice.
Why does she need to be above now?
I don't know, do they?
Why don't they start moving like the one on the left, though?
You see, like this?
Starts moving it like this.
I feel better already.
I can't with the mones.
See, it's like, it's making it worse.
It's making it worse.
So much worse.
I have an idea.
Let's see.
Wow.
Fuck off.
I'll be honest, a part of me is very tempted right now to go to a fucking YouTube video
and just see how they fucking solve this shit.
Cause I'm fucking stupid.
We're just making an update and making the ropes go away.
Don't I need to get the ropes away from him?
Why do people put the ropes away?
Cause he's a freak.
Igor is a freak.
You can touch the bear for help, though?
No, it doesn't do anything.
Keep clicking on him and it doesn't do anything.
They said make the right pattern at the start.
What is the right pattern, though?
What does that even mean?
What does the right pattern mean?
Fuck this one, honestly, fuck this whale.
The net.
But we're trying to get him out, though.
So, like, what the fuck?
Good logs, keep it up.
Like, doesn't make sense.
How is we trying to get him out?
Why the fuck are we trying to...?
Good logs, keep it up.
This is a game called Google it.
The name of the game is in the title.
I just looked up video and you're doing this wrong.
Just try. You have nothing to lose in this one.
That's not true. I'm losing.
I am losing everything right now.
I am losing my dignity by playing this fucking game.
Showing everyone how fucking stupid I am.
So, yeah, that's just great.
Like this?
Okay.
Isn't this the right pattern? Like, what does it mean?
This looks like the right pattern to me.
Right?
Time making the square-net pattern.
I know. What the fuck?
You have to make a tic-tac-toe pattern with the ropes.
You need to use all ropes?
Okay.
Oh my god, shut up. Please, please.
You're making this? You're making this so fucking difficult, Lars.
Please, I'm begging.
Oh my god.
Please.
How do I feel better?
Literally how?
What are you doing?
Okay.
Lars, keep it up.
What is this?
Hello.
Bro, I think...
What the fuck?
Oh my god. Why are you like this?
Bro.
I'm literally like, dying right now. What the fuck is going on?
You know, I thought this is going to be as simple.
Can you see the puzzle?
But I was really fucking wrong, apparently.
Bro, where is...
Where are the other ropes?
Like, hello?
Oh my...
It's so hard to believe.
Oh my god.
You might actually have to restart.
Fuck, not again.
Oh, I feel better already.
Please.
Oh my god.
They're off the screen.
Okay, we're...
Whenever you want to come back and play with me.
Literally the worst remember.
What the fuck is this shit?
Fuck my life.
What the fuck is this?
Okay, I see no.
I'm fucking dying.
I'm literally dying right now from embarrassment.
From how stupid I am.
From how difficult this fucking game is.
What the fuck?
Do you need a hug?
I need you.
I don't need a hug.
I need you to finish this fucking game for me.
That's what I need.
I'm so sorry, Oji-san.
I'm not the smartest tool in the shit.
Oh my god.
I'm sorry.
I'm really sorry Snow Bear is for this shitty stream.
I apologize.
I did not think this puzzle was going to be hard.
But I was fucking wrong apparently.
Before we go and see Ego, we'll have to catch some food.
I'm going to have PTSD from this game.
When a fish jumps out of the water,
catch it as fast as you can.
Use your mouth to move my paw
and click on the fish as they jump out of the water.
I can fish just fine.
That's not the problem here, okay?
I know what to do.
I can fish just fine.
Easy.
Great.
We have enough supplies.
Let's go and see Ego.
We're in mode mode?
No, it's not.
I'm playing and I'm playing.
Oh god.
Okay.
Here we go again.
What happened to you?
Lars, I'm stuck in this fishing net.
Please help me get out by pulling on the ropes
to put them in the right order.
We'll have to use all our strength to pull these ropes.
When it comes to games that require brain,
I don't think...
I feel better already.
Please stop Egor, please.
I'm begging you.
Please.
Um...
I feel better already.
Okay.
Come on.
I feel better already.
Okay, Egor, here you go.
You're gonna have to stop moaning.
I'm trying to focus here and you're really...
and you're really you're just you're just not helping okay i understand you're enjoying this a lot but
please let me let me show you something
oh
why is it so hard oh my fucking
um
that is my life now come on
please
save me
you're not helping me go you're really not helping me um
it's all over for me
matters will graduate right now
from all the shame i have gathered from playing this fucking game
like what the fuck is this oh my god please
i'm dead
please i just i just
oh
oh my god i'm so close
oh my god i'm so small come on stupid fucking ropes i swear to
fucking god i swear to fucking god i'm going to heal these ropes shut up lars
shut up this is not the time to moan okay we are doing
yo yo yo i did it i did it yay i did it let's go it feels good to get my
let's go ask you another favor sure Igor what you want me to do
hi she be why did you put drops all over Igor you made this game so difficult for me
oh now what
oh we can sit we can sit Igor now
yum yum yum yummy fish for Igor now you can finally eat yum yum yum yum
you like it Igor my fish for you
you're supposed to say two what do you mean one it's one two he doesn't know how to count
i feel much better yay you're welcome now i can get out of this ice prison wait Igor
i have a question for you can you tell me about the great bear
hmm i'm afraid i can't help you but i helped you my friend the elk will know
you can ask him but first you'll have to find his herd
i've helped you you can fly on Sally's back or jump from iceberg to iceberg across the water
oh what should i do
what should i do what do you think would be more fun time him back up i'd rather not i would
generally rather not tie him back up i was kind i was gonna come back eventually maybe no no you
why are you just gonna live here with Igor and his moaning okay so what do we want to do
jumping or fly on the dock give him to the fisherman i don't know what to do they're both some fun
don't mess with the keys oh i don't know which one to choose i kind of want to fly
oh i want to fly i'm gonna fly i think that would be cool yeah look at me
hold on tight we're going to have to avoid many obstacles okay the trip won't be long
but it will be dangerous use your mouth to direct my flight okay nice
wow look at us go and i can you fly faster please
oh my god that scared the shit out of me what the fuck oh no i killed her okay maybe we shouldn't
go fast oh i'm scared i'm scared oh my god oh no i'm so sorry that scared me so much
oh my god that scared the shit out of me
oh oh this was so scary i didn't mean to kill her mid flight i was like let's fly faster
and then she fucking dies
ah
i should have went with the jumping
oh no i'm scared
i'm scared
oh i'm scared i should have i should have listened to a g-sons and and chose jumping on ice blocks
this is scary
okay we can do this we can do this we can do this oh come on we can do this
i can do this
okay thank god let's go down and rest okay thank god oh i was so terrified oh thank god this is
over with i had like the anxiety of my life oh look it's sheebie how are you i'm great bars
hey do you want to have a snowball fight with me sure she be let's go great idea all right if you
want to beat me you'll have to hit me three times let's go let's hit she be okay she be where are you
let me hit you bam bam i'm so good for you lars you're really good yeah yeah we've had our fun
let's get going where we're going on this iceberg until it melts i don't think that's funny
where we're gonna live we have to find his herd hurry let's get going let's go
oh no can you see us sure you can look carefully we're way up on the top
you see that little white spot over here it's us to find him we have to cross the maze on this
why the exit you get us out of here i hope this maze isn't too dangerous
she be why the hell did you choose the most inconvenient way to go somewhere what is your
problem why you do this to me what's their rope not enough
look at us swimming oh this is easy this is easy this is easy look i'm so smart
yay we made it we made it i must say for a while i was really afraid we would get lost come on
i was not afraid i knew the way about the ice you weren't afraid when we had our snowball fight
yes but this time there was an awful lot more ice
my friend the wolf has to cross the river but he can't swim the problem is that our boat is too
that is a weird looking wall that does not look like
i need your help click on the one you want to cross and i'll take care of the rest
of course you know you can't leave Hugo and the wolf together and you can't leave Hugo and the
carrot next to each other try not to leave me too close to the wall okay i gotta i think at me
don't worry you don't have to be scared of me oh god okay let's let's move she be first
that's a good start
good for you you made the right choices you're all able to cross the river are you proud of me
are you proud of me oh Jesus look how smart i am yay i'm smart
oh what's this we're almost in elk territory we have to get through the forest first okay the
wolves are on the lookout they mustn't catch me i'm counting on you to guide me this is
oh no go on get out
oh god
okay
i'm so fucking chunky i can't move
god
we're gonna be here a while
come on come on come on so close so close no what the fuck was that why did i just
why is he so fast that's bullshit oh no no no no
oh no no no no oh oh
oh god it's all over for me
please
this stupid fucking
let me get my coffee
this is stupid they're cheating why are they so fast
they're stopping fast
that's cheating
oh god oh no oh please please let me have this let me win oh i'm so close i'm so close i'm so
please
guide me to the exit i'm so close what the fuck
fuck
i'm so mad i was so close
i was so close
scram
no
i was so stupid no fucking
i'm watch out for the wolves
shut up
i was so fucking
scram
to fuck you
why is he so fucking fast
Yes, leave me alone, please.
Scram.
He didn't even touch me.
Watch out for the wolves.
That was bullshit.
He didn't even touch me.
What the fuck?
Come on.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Every fucking time.
Fuck off.
Shut up, bitch.
Leave me alone.
God, it's me.
Scram.
Guide me to the exit.
And watch out for the wolves.
Why is this getting so difficult?
Scram.
It's the ground.
I hate this.
Why do I keep getting stuck in the air?
God, fucking dammit.
Hello?
Fuck off.
Scram.
I'm so fucking mad.
Fuck you.
To fuck off.
You know what to fuck off.
Fuck you.
Scram.
Guide me to the exit.
And watch out for the wolves.
I'm so sick of it.
What the fuck?
Scram.
Please.
Please, I just, I just wanted to have fun.
No, I'm suffering.
Oh, God, I don't know where the fuck to go.
They always get me.
Please, please let me have this.
Please let me have this.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Hey.
Thanks to you, I have arrived safe and sound.
And sound in elk territory.
Fuck you wolves.
Let's hurry up and find him.
Fuck you, bitch.
I haven't seen him in such a long time.
I'm not sure I'll recognize him.
Thanks to you, I have arrived safe and sound.
Oh, my God.
Fucking fine.
I'm thinking.
Oh, that's a lot of horses.
There are a lot of elks.
And I don't see Ed anywhere.
Oh, I thought it's some wolves.
Could you please help me find him?
I'll help you by killing you what I remember about him.
It's up to you to eliminate the elk that don't match Ed's description.
Ed's hair is very short.
Um.
Ed's antlers are not heart shaped.
What do you want?
I mean, I just said what do you want from me?
Ed sees with both his eyes.
Oh, no.
Ed doesn't have a patch on his eye.
If I remember correctly, he has two antlers.
Don't they both have two antlers?
It's antlers are very short.
Okay.
Ed doesn't have a beard.
Yes.
Ed is well shaven.
Ed has a tail.
Okay.
Does it tell you to click the one that don't have the description?
Hello, lords.
Oh, it's been a very long time since we last saw each other.
It's so nice of you to come and see me.
Yeah, it's been nine years.
What's happened to you, Ed?
There was a storm.
Sometimes the wind blows so hard.
It blows my antlers away.
What?
Help me put the knife together.
Are I doing what I can?
To move a piece of Ed's antler, click on it.
When there is an empty box nearby,
the piece will place itself there automatically.
Um...
Oh, no!
That's my bus!
You can't mess.
Oh, my fucking god.
Oh, my god.
Please.
Why did I think this game was good?
Fuck.
Oh, my god.
Oh, no.
Oh, what am I doing?
What the fuck is my problem?
I know what's my problem.
I'm fucking stupid.
Oh, my god.
Ah!
I'm so sorry.
Yeah, I would not survive this game without embarrassing myself.
Well, good thing I'm playing it so you don't have to embarrass yourself.
I can do that for you.
Live on streaming.
Please.
Please, I'm begging.
Oh, my god.
It's so over.
What the fuck?
Hello?
Okay.
I mean, this looks...
I mean, this looks right to me.
So, what's the fucking problem?
Oh, no.
I mean, this looks so right.
It looks flip.
How do I flip?
I need flippers and check.
Oh, my god.
Why am I doing this to myself?
Why did I go?
Oh, yeah, this is a good game.
Yeah.
This is exactly what we need.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, my god.
I feel much better.
Yeah, I'm glad you feel better.
I clearly don't.
I'm glad you all feel better, but I do not feel that great.
So, you're welcome for the sacrifice of my own emotions.
You're welcome.
I mean, okay, let's be fair.
Let's be fair.
It's to be expected that I'm this dumb, you know?
I am literally a feral polar bear, okay?
I haven't been in civilization long enough.
Just so fucking puzzle today.
I hope you'll see each other again soon.
I hope so too, Lars. Take care.
Would you rather cross the Arctic Ocean on Igor's back
or slide down the mountain?
Ooh.
What should we do?
What should we choose?
They both sound fun.
Yeah, what should we do?
Slide down the mountain?
Or ride on Igor's back?
Slide, slide.
No more Igor, please.
Okay, okay, okay.
Let's slide this now.
Are you ready for your adventure?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm ready to slide on this now.
Let's go.
At last.
We're at the top of the mountain.
I didn't think we'd ever make it.
I mean, honestly, me too.
I did not think we would make it either.
Quick, let's get down the mountain.
Guide my movements and avoid the obstacles.
Otherwise, the avalanche will catch us.
Okay, let's go.
Look at me go.
Wow.
What a slide.
Slide.
No.
That sounds.
No, no.
Won't it be even more stupid?
Because I hit my head against the fucking rock.
Wee.
Rip it.
oh my god let's fuck you oh you're safe I didn't think we'd make it I'm going
let's get going we've got a ways to go yet
oh nice all right she be again look it's she be
Lars wait for me there's a storm coming take cover okay
wow that's what you call a storm
haha that's for sure hey look at those nests up there the storm must have shaken them around
the eggs are getting ready to fall well done lars well done well done lars hang on Hugo well done lars
yo we could make like some nice breakfast was she
all of the eggs are safety sound phew that's right we managed to avoid any scramble legs
that would be a disaster
here we are in front of the ice bridge but it's been destroyed luckily the pieces are still here
and it can be put back together okay take them and put them in their places I mean I can
once you put the bridge back together I'll be able to cross swim could just swim um
oh god oh no
that's it
can I rotate them
doing great I'm not doing great why are you lying to me getting gas lit by lars over here why are you
lying to me that's it
this looks like you're doing great what the fuck
what do you mean this looks like the perfect piece for it
what the that's it that did what that did nothing what do you mean
oh my god please doing great shut up stop whining oh god
that's it
that did did that did
doing great oh
okay oh okay that's it shut up
nice
doing great oh my god please stop you're you're not helping okay why are you not helping me
that's it oh my god shut up oh my god okay
okay
doing great like this
nice where did I put this one here that did
pick up the pieces of the bridge and place them correctly there's more oh there's a sound we'll
tell you during ladies in the wrong place I'm sorry I'm blind I didn't notice the last piece
good for you go rebuild the bridge now we will be able to cross yeah let's rest the bridge
we'll make it to walters before dark let's hurry
look at my big dumpster my dump is so big
yay
according to ed walters cave is just behind those trees but the path is blocked
walters cave oh I know what walter is doing in this cave
what do I need to do
um click on the trees in the right order to repeat the trees melody okay the trees will let us
through sooner or later why am I so stupid
okay
oh no oh no I'm forgetting I'm forgetting
oh no oh no it's all it's all clumping together oh no I can't tell the difference I can't tell the
difference oh god
oh
fucking god oh my god I thought we're gonna be stuck here for 10 you played the notes in the
right order now we can get through let's hope it will be dark soon and we won't be able to see
anything
yay
remember again sir apparently we must find walter but I don't remember where he lives
you'll have to help me find his tracks in the snow a lot of animals go through here
to find walter we'll have to be sure that we're not confusing him with an other animal okay
you can identify all the animals the last one will surely be walter
hmm okay where is walter walter is busy making a special uh special fun candies
um
um what am I supposed to do um hello
I um
my dad went through here I wonder where he was going where is dad
uh
yay okay I'm figuring you know I am figuring this out
um
um my friend the wolf went by here I hope I'll get to see him he always tells good stories
wow nice story
Ed and his herd have been through here
nice
good job thank you now that we know where walter is let's not lose any time let's go find him
walter he's walter
hey walter
give me a walter
hello
walter I finally found you how are you
walter looking a bit different
Finn's hurt the fish are getting scarce I have more and more trouble catching them
but tell me what brings you so far from home I've come to see you because they say you know
lots of things I'd like to know why we sometimes call the big dipper the great bear you mean you
don't know well you've come to the right walrus I don't know I can tell you stories about all of
the stars we'll have to wait until it gets dark then we'll look together and I'll tell you the
story in the meantime let's play my favorite game okay let's play we'll take turns I'll take the
X's and you take the O's the first one to make a vertical horizontal or diagonal line wins okay okay
okay let's do this okay I guess I go first what the fuck is that sound
oh
do you want to play one last round
no let me win
win
what the heck
do you want to play one last round
walter let me win
this is
nice move
god damn it stop
good for you lars you won yes you're very good
yeah I am
it's already dark out time certainly went by quickly
okay let's look at the stars I'll tell you the legend of the great bear just as my father told me
okay but why do they call it that
as I promised I'm going to tell you another legend about the great bear
once upon a time longer ago than any walrus can remember humans lived in peace with all the
animals in the world the wisest among them was a man who was married to a very beautiful woman
alas she died a short time after they were married leaving him in despair
his grief drove him crazy and he took his most beautiful bow and shot many arrows into the sky
but he shot his bow so hard that each arrow tore a hole in the sky giving birth to a star
light came streaming out of those stars toward the earth and fell on the archer who had created them
everyone in the village watched in wonder and when the light had dispersed they saw that the
archer had become a bear as white as you lars the hunters were terrified and wanted to kill the
bear man who had to flee for his life he walked and walked for a very long time before he arrived
in our land of ice and snow in this white land of ours he discovered a simpler life than that of
people and he at last found the peace that had disappeared when his wife died the constellation
was named after that lovesick archer the four stars that formed the square were born with his arrows
i'm just a cob represent the hunters who chased away oh boy i have no idea i'm certainly glad i came
to see you walter i'm not now i know that all the bears on earth have something in common that brings
us together and you like that that was depressing why are you telling me this but i should be getting
home now my parents are going to get worried you still have a few games playing some new friends to
me i'll tell you another story when you finish i don't want to hear another story you're so depressing
um
um hello whenever you want to come back and play with me all you have to do is click on the friend
that you chose the beginning see you soon no i almost closed the game i wanted i want to like
i want to go back i want to go back and like choose the other choice i want to choose the other choices
like you know how we had two choices to do like different stuff i want to pick the choices i didn't
choose choose one of my friends i can play all of them you will be a playmate and remember our
adventure are you sure of your choice yeah don't forget with animal you chose it will allow you to
come back to your game where you left off one more this is the north pole lars has always lived here
there are two ways to follow lars's adventure you can play with ours and help along on his adventure
in the game or you can follow his adventure like a storybook oh i thought it's gonna save and i could
like help during the game just click on lars and they'll give you some help if it's a safe
why do i need to redo this like i should be able to click and choose
what the f
yeah i i my my save where i finished all of the game was the owl one right
but i clicked the owl and it acts like it didn't save you last saved on dog
really well you want to come back and play with me
let me let me check the dog
let me see let me see let me see
everyone is going to have a dream about this game tonight
hello from how many times you've seen this scene to start our adventure lars choose one of my friends
he will be your playmate and remember our adventure i'm sure of your choice yeah yeah yeah this is the
north pole what the f did i just say there are two ways to follow lars's adventure you can play
with lars and help him along on his adventure in the game or you can follow his adventure like a
storybook oh and one last thing if you need any help during the game just click on lars and he'll give
you some help whenever you want to come back and play with me fuck you no no i'm not redoing the
no i'm not redoing the ropes fuck you shut up not redoing the ropes shut up oh great now i need to
fucking fix my freaking settings oh my god where's where's my display
hey where's my display fix
oh my god this this game holy fuck wait where am i oh no i'm gone hello
hello what the fuck where am i where am i hello oh why am i so big what the fuck
why am i so big hello what the fuck
why am i so big make me smaller i'll make me smaller the fuck
what the fuck this smaller
oh my god why is it so weird
it's supposed to be like full size
but then it's too small why why small oh wow whatever uh i need to i need to reposition
myself i need to reposition myself okay okay oh my god that really sucks i i remember like
i remember watching like a playthrough of this game and you know when they did uh the save thing
then you could like click the save file and then you could choose what mini game to play
but i don't know why it doesn't why doesn't work right now what the fuck
uh can we have the entire visible portion of your motto be a midriff
oh
let me see like this
like this is that what you mean it's a boggy mouseboy you were great i see why why
why why
i see weight loss oh my god you don't have to drink water yeah yeah yeah hold on let me
let me mute my mic and and drink some water
you
proper tummy very nice yes very nice i like this room so far thank you i'm i'm glad
that face though a lot of drinking sounds that no
i feel better already i'm glad that's very good um you did your best for a game that was made
produced in the 80s early 90s made with moon magic for an upper assistant wheel with the
why we have now you did great i see thank you but like we still have like 30 minutes together
what should we do
sorry i'm trying to get more comfy
also environment manager
you mean you mean strani yeah yeah yeah i know but we still have like 30 minutes together
uh we can always yap paperback scissors the app session you should sample lars voice for your
dj stream oh god that's gonna be terrible uh nothing more chatting uh what games you're
planning on playing in the future um i plan on playing a lot of retro games that um that i
have showed on my debut uh 2.0 uh i showed like a list of like some of my favorite games and i
want to play them on stream eventually uh sample eager smoaning oh my god okay that would be kind
of funny wait what if i did that that would be fucking hilarious imagine i do the dj stream and
then you hear his moaning i don't know what that would be pretty fucking funny
uh my god i'm glad this stream is going well i see why do you drive and if so
i don't i don't i don't drive i don't even have a driving license i'm a polar bear why would i have
why would i drive why would i have a driving license you know i'm just a polar bear i
don't need any of that you know can you hint what next week will be uh do you um do you mean like
schedule wise um well next week i i'm gonna have two asmr streams that's the plan anyways
i i really want to first see like the feedback i guess after tomorrow stream basically if in
tomorrow's asmr stream uh you know goes well and you like it uh then my plan is uh next week to
have two asmr streams but that's but that's like um that's assuming that you you will you will like
it because like because because like if i do an asmr stream tomorrow and everyone is like
man that shit fucking sucks i hate the background noise it ruins it it's fucking trash um i'm gonna
have to do probably something else because you know i don't want to do an asmr stream if if if uh
you're not going to enjoy it obviously we would never we will love it it will be great
i have feeling people will like it now i'm gonna kill tomorrow uh i guess i just i guess i keep
getting worried about background noise because like i want to like with where i live right now
i'm not allowed to like modify anything in the apartment so only when like
i move around like september i'll be trying to find an apartment where like i could have like
a room and make sure to like uh you know put like those thingies so that uh it's it's good for asmr
and a quiet and stuff because right now like you can hear what the 3do like picks up um what my
neighbors do anything like like upstairs or when like carves drive outside like from the window
or like if anyone talks like outside like out the window then you can hear it too so
i guess i'm pretty nervous about that uh you'll do great now that yourself will be fine so
hard any of this oh well that's because i'm not using the 3do right now this mic uh doesn't pick up
anywhere as much as uh anywhere as much as the 3do gonna love your voice doing ASMR i hope so i hope
you will enjoy it uh i'm sure it would be fantastic no matter what i see and the background noise
doesn't bother us imi had background noise and it was still great uh i feel like her background
noise was like very minimal so that's why i'm worried um blah blah blah blah uh i forgot what
do you think about singing stream uh do you mean like a karaoke stream i am uh by no means a good
singer uh i can't sing or anything but i do plan on doing some karaoke streams but like you know
just for fun like when i do karaoke streams i'm like fucking around basically so so if you
ever come to my karaoke streams please don't expect me to like sing well or anything like that it's
just for the big funny blah blah blah blah yes karaoke would be great yeah i would have to be
drunk karaoke it would have to be drunk karaoke because like uh because uh blah blah blah i would
be nervous singing otherwise let me let me change to my my just my just chatting things i can be like
okay okay now now now that's that's a bit better i think
that's a bit better now now i'm like now you can see me now you can see me a lot better while we
yap together uh did she be scared taking down too yeah her her got taken i think i think mercy
is the only one so far that didn't have her but take it down isolation from is pretty good
seven proofing windows yeah i i hope that will work uh let me let me put on oh the bgm is on okay
never mind it's it's on uh let's see what else sorry i'm trying to like scroll through through
the chat and stuff like that um look chat i'll have my pen lights i read it as penis lights not
gonna lie like i've read what you said i'll have my pen lights out for ic and i read it as something
else chance of russian songs in karaoke um maybe maybe maybe i could find like a song or
tour or something like that drunk karaoke sounds even more fun yeah it will be fun i i get like
even more ridiculous when i drink so it will be even more fun let's hear a drink of choice for
drunk karaoke DJ streams i usually um just try to find uh the sweetest wine that i can find and
then drink like pretty much almost the whole bottle what matters to me is that the wine is sweet
if it's sweet then i'm happy if it's like dry and bitter then i don't i don't like it
yeah let's see
chat chat chat
mrs was very careful with her stream yeah i i i don't know what's gonna happen in my stream
i'll be honest whatever feels natural i'm just gonna go with whatever feels right because i need
to buy some ASMR triggers i i don't have uh i don't have too much right now
rap i might try but i'm probably gonna suck at it
um
i see can you do a stream where you teach us russian
i i could try but i feel like i would be a really terrible teacher
like i don't know what it is but i don't feel i feel like i'm not good at teaching i don't know
but maybe maybe if it was something that you were interested in um
will you perhaps do a russian ASMR stream in the future i see uh i already got asked this question
on one of my moros actually uh so during my ASMR streams uh if enough people want me to uh i can
definitely uh you know do some russian like here and there i don't want it to be like the main
focus or anything like i want to keep it in english and stuff but i could like maybe like do some
russian words here and there or like um russian sentences sentences uh here and there uh i feel
like that would be okay do you drink vodka if i drink vodka i like it to be flavored like there
is a lot of vodkas that are like flavored and they're like sweet but then again yeah if it's
sweet and flavor then yeah uh are you a lightweight yeah i am i'm i'm very lightweight to be honest
especially with wine
um
if you're creative almost anything can be used for ASMR yeah exactly you can make sounds
with like anything really but i want to make sure that the sounds are good but then again like
ASMR triggers is like there's there's always people who are going to like some triggers
and people who don't like some triggers so if you see me doing like a trigger then you're not a
big fan of you can always just like mute and unmute when i am done so there's that
uh you could just roast us when we don't get it uh i know i could but i don't know i i think
i'm gonna keep it like nice and and cute for the ASMR streams are you better at russian than
english i'm actually no actually no i am better at english than in russian because i rarely speak
russian at this point like i only speak russian uh with my parents you know so because i rarely use
russian uh you know when like you don't use a language much uh with time you you know forget
some words and stuff like that so sometimes when i talk to my parents i need to like google
certain words and like i'm trying to like explain stuff and i'm like what's the word for that what's
the word for this and that and i'm just uh yeah so my russian is not as good as it used to be
because i just speak english 99 of the time you know and i only use russian with my parents so
let me see
hey i was wondering if ASMR vods are locked behind patreon uh no we're we're not we're not supposed
to have vods in our patreon because apparently youtube is making a fuss about it and it's not
allowed or something like that um so you know again if if you want to make sure that you have a
vod then you will have to archive it or hope that anyone else archives it and like shares a link for
it um i think she should do an ASMR where she drinks ice water that would actually make like a pretty
good sound like if i if i got like some ice and i put it like in the water and then i moved it around
that actually makes for a really nice trigger so yeah the only two triggers i don't like are eating
and marker sound what is what is marker sounds like when you use a marker and like draw with it or
what do you mean um
are you born and raised in russia no i was actually born i was born in ukraine
and my parents uh taught me russian instead of ukrainian because they were like russian is used
a lot more than ukrainian so they decided to just teach me russian instead uh but yeah i'm
i'm ukrainian like i was i was born in ukraine but uh i speak russian because that's what my parents
taught me when i was a child um let me see
oh this uh sorry i'm i'm still i'm still trying to like to like uh try and read everything
and it's hard so i'm sorry if i if i miss some stuff uh i'm not used to having uh chat uh have
so much to say and stuff so uh please please uh please excuse me
um fuck
bone eating sounds when you like sounds that sound like breaking bones do sound pretty good
oh wow interesting i see lord yeah i guess i was speaking of like that i i want to do a zatsu
stream eventually i want to do a zatsu stream eventually where i talk about all of my good
memories back in ukraine and and i was thinking of actually like sharing some photos uh from back then
as well uh i want i was i i wonder if it's something that you guys would be interesting with
i i could like talk about my best memories and also show you photographs from from you know from
my childhood and stuff
the ic lora runs deeper live to hear more of it yeah eventually you'll hear a lot of it because
there's a lot of memories that i have and stuff like that uh i'm constantly happy every day just
from thinking about you thank you oh that's really sweet thank you thank you i love to hear
best how the memories i'm glad because because i have a lot of them and it will make me really happy
to uh to talk about them and show you some nice photographs and stuff like that
how is ukraine i have very good memories from it to be honest like a lot of the good memories
that i'll be sharing in my zatsu are from like uh from uh more like uh a countryside of ukraine
uh because basically we lived in an apartment but we also had like a summer house farm thingy
that my grandpa has built and so we would spend a lot of time uh in that house so basically my
grandparents like grew vegetables and fruits over there and it was just really really nice over there
but yeah i have like so many good memories i actually like i wanna
sorry i i want to write down all of the memories so that i remember
sorry so i remember uh to to i can't talk i'm getting nervous i don't know why
so i can talk about all those good memories and not forget about basically uh because i
make for really nice and good good memories you know uh also
also i i noticed that uh i got a donation yesterday when i wasn't screaming so i do want to thank
the person who did that uh so thank you i don't know if you're here in the room right now but
op thank you so much for the 30 dollar donation uh loving the watch so far i see
they really help get through the day they're so cute and fun and it's great to see you hitting
your stride oh thank you that makes me happy i'm glad that i can like help you get through the day
with my big silliness and big dumb dumb moments and stuff like that
yes i'm already a hiccup drunk ASMR i mean you're gonna hear my hiccups like either way
either way during the ASMR stream even tomorrow so uh i don't even need to be drunk for that to
happen i see being cute no matter what she does uh i'm i'm glad i'm glad that you think that because
there's a lot of moments where i'm like uh i don't know if i'm cute and i don't know if i'm
if i'm like i don't know sometimes sometimes i get worried and insecure and worried that i'm not
cute enough and stuff um i'm happy that you want to share so much with us yeah of course i think
i think it's such a nice thing to i don't know like share these like stuff you know
it just like brings brings me joy to be able to talk about it uh to to people who want to listen
to it you know because like i could talk to anyone about this stuff but it's not the same
if they don't really want to listen so so like hearing that you do want me to do a zatsu stream
just tapping about my good memories and share photographs from childhood makes me happy because
it's like oh thanks they actually carry on and they want to hear it you know so that's that's
really nice uh you're always cute i see don't mean secure you're an adorable princess thank you i'm
trying i'm trying uh every every stream i i will get more and more confident and then
a year from now hopefully uh i will gain much more confidence
i can listen to icf about everything play games i'm glad that makes me happy to hear that
um i see epic big content yeah i'm glad you think so i'm glad you don't find it like
annoying i guess sometimes i'm also worried that like i talk too much and i'm like
and i'm just like man who cares like wow you know
man i i need to figure out like why am i trying to pause this sometimes
i don't understand why it does that like my cpu is completely fine like there's nothing wrong with
it and phone is charged do a thing
i gotta see a teeny baby kaba i see yeah you're well that's why i'm super cute i really like
how chill your streams are the other girls are cool too but sometimes it's sensory overload for me
i'm i'm surprised you're saying that like i feel like mine is very sensory overload if anything
because because you know especially today like i was just like screaming a lot today and getting
jump scared and and like getting loud and i feel i feel if there's someone who is sensory
overload that's me honestly to be honest
i love your accent though i always like when you talk thank you i'm i'm glad to hear that
how much you hear that um
annoying and i should never be used in a sentence oh that's sweet
maybe the connection between your phone and computer causing freezes could that be it i wonder
i wonder if that could be that i'm not sure maybe i'll hopefully hopefully i can figure that out
blah blah blah blah blah blah
it's such a nice contrast to your normal talking voice wait what do you mean when i'm like
like do you mean like my yapping voice or something like that or are you talking about like
when i do like ASMR or something sorry i'm i'm a bit confused i guess a little bit confused
would you play a horror game in the future you have really funny reactions to being scared
yeah definitely definitely i i would definitely want to play uh some horror games in the future
yeah i think that would be really fun and and you snowberries can can keep me company and and help
me when i'm scared because because i would definitely need that i i feel like if i play
Silent Hill 3 i'm definitely gonna need your help to to keep me safe because because that
game is just so scary to me but i really want to play it
tip link is broken i see wait is that
um
let me see if it works for me
it works for me you just when you click it you need to click uh
i can't talk you need to after you click the link you need to click on the top right on the
dollar icon and it will forward you to the tip
is your phone plugged into your pc uh no it doesn't why is it supposed to be
me isn't supposed to be plugged in my pc why won't i do that or no i cut i'm using like bluetooth
for it
warning do not let icy play rage games like getting over it or the rock pushing game she
will abide oh my god i actually be actually played before getting over it and i could not like
pass like even the first like obstacle and it was just me freaking like raging so much it was
oh my god i i refunded the game after that it was like i hate this so much but it was really
funny it did it it it was like really fucking funny at some point i was just dying laughing
playing some whore puzzle game i would prefer if there's less puzzles puzzles as possible
because um big dumb
i think you should um my son to check out the description that the url for tipics is
tip at the end so people get that they were streaming i actually i actually like try to
edit it myself and for some reason it didn't save it when i did that but i don't know i'm
i'm gonna try and do it again see if that see if that fixes it i guess uh bluetooth is i can't
talk bluetooth is not as good as wired connection okay maybe maybe i will try to
sorry my nose was itchy i'll i'll try to uh plug in the phone uh enter my computer and see if that
helps guess you can say you didn't really get over it yeah i i never got over it not not even
me
maybe it sounds mean but i want to see a shout and scream in a game just once i mean i screamed
and shouted at the game today like a lot like i was so frustrated with the stupid freaking rope
puzzle it was just so annoying i'm off to work now have a nice have a good night i see and thank
you for the stream bye bye have a good day at work take care thank you for stopping by
i see sniffing is more when one hour i've got i don't know if i could do like a full hour of
sniffing that would kill me but a little bit here and there oh maybe i could do some sniffing
tomorrow maybe i could do some a little bit of sniffing in tomorrow's ASMR like here and there
you go ptsd okay literally though i feel so much better
it's gonna be too funny
hopefully if you do the retro point and click adventure guess it won't be as bad as the little
polar bear yeah i hope so too because um there's uh actually a few point and click games that i
would like to uh to play and stand eventually so i think that would be very very nice i can't
really remember the names of them to be honest but um yeah uh let me see i need to check something
in my settings uh yes please that would be so cute sniffing and some power-ups yeah that would
be really cute and oh and i could like uh i could also like give you a hug as well i i i know i don't
know if you remember but i was but i was talking about uh giving some hug ASMR where like i cut
all the in my arms and like
something something like that you know i see hugs let's go yay can we give you belly wraps
hmm i don't know about that
i don't know i don't know you have no not yet no not yet
maybe maybe maybe someday uh hotbeds hotbeds are okay hotbeds are okay but tommy wraps i don't
know not not quite yet not quite yet
ten dollar per one belly
not yet we have a chance yeah you have a chance if if you behave have a chance if you behave
not getting hugs from my scenes unbearable uh it will be unbearable once you experience how
how nice and cuddly uh my hugs are i try my best to give some really really cute hugs
but yeah i'm definitely gonna you know do my very best tomorrow and really hope that you can enjoy
my ASMR as much as possible
why about hotbeds yeah yeah hotbeds are okay hotbeds are okay
what about paw hauling uh eventually eventually eventually but i don't know
i don't know i mean it's not really ASMR like i don't think
i don't think that would really work for it so i like i don't think
it would really make like a sound or anything like that but anyways uh i'm gonna end the stream
here for now and um i'm gonna redirect you to strongy stream uh i will see you again tomorrow
at the same time and tomorrow uh i will be doing ASMR and i will try my best to do it as best as i can
um if you if you seem to like it a lot uh maybe i'll try to go for even more than two hours but
it depends on how it goes it depends on how it goes if if the background sound is too loud then
i just keep it at two hours but we will see we will see okay thank you again snowberries for
coming into my stream thank you for keeping me company and and watching me struggle with this
with this freaking game puzzles uh i hope you enjoyed uh seeing me struggle a lot and uh
i'll see you again tomorrow don't miss me too much bye bye for now bye bye snowberries
uh big kids bye bye